نشير مشاهدينا الكرام الى طائفه من
الاخبار العاجله تظهر على شاشتنا تباعا
القناه الثال ع الاسرائيليه تنقل عن
مسؤولين اسرائيليين ان الصفقه المطروحه
تتضمن اطلاق 30 الى 40 رهينه مقابل اطلاق
سراح اسرى فلسطينيين بارزين كذلك تقول
القناه الثاله ع الاسرائيليه نقلا عن
مسؤولين اسرائيليين ان الصفقه تتضمن
انسحابا جزئيا من بعض مناطق التهدئه او من
بعض المناطق مع تهدئه من اسبوعين الى شهر
وتشير او تنقل القناه الثاله عش
الاسرائيليه ايضا عن مسؤولين ان هذه
الصفقه ان تمت خلال الانتقال للمرحله
التاليه فقد يتم تغيير ترتيبات عسكريه
بغزه القناه الث ع الاسرائيليه تنقل كذلك
عن مسؤولين انه لا مشكله لدى اسرائيل بربط
حماس التغيير العسكري بالصفقه واعتباره
انجازا اي يمكن لحماس ان تسوق لنفسها هذا
ما يقوله المسؤولون الاسرائيليون و وتنقله
القناه الثالثه عشره الاسرائيليه وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه يقول سنعمل على
اغتيال اسماعيل هنيه وخالد مشعل ولن يموتا
موتا طبيعيا وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
يقول ايضا سنرسل رئيس المساد الى كل مكان
لاجراء محادثات بهدف اعاده المخطوفين
ينضم الينا من الخليل الدكتور بلال
الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الخليل اي هذه الاخبار العاجله لفت
نظرك اكثر من غيره استاذ
بلال يعني حقيقه الامر انه
هناك تصريح واضح جدا من ال وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي بشان اغتيال قيادات في حركه
حماس هذا برايي اعلان الافلاس بشكل واضح
من مستوى سياسي عالي بمعنى عدم القدره على
تحقيق اي اهداف تذكر داخل قطاع غزه
والذهاب الى استسهال يعني اغتيال قيادات
سياسيه وهذا بالامر يعني الذي يعني ليس
بالجديد بالنسبه لاسرائيل ومكرر وهذا الذي
يجعلنا نسميه افلاسام انه اذا كانت
اسرائيل كانت قد اعلنت مرارا انها ستقوض
حركه حماس ومن ثم انتقلت الى مرحله تقويض
حكم حماس ولاحقا الى تفكيك البنيه
التنظيميه هم يتحدثوا الان عن اغتيال
شخصيات في حركه حماس مع بقاء حركه حماس
على الارض وبقاء حركه حماس على الارض ليست
مجرد عمليه استنتاجات من من محللين وانما
هي ما تنقله الصصور من خلال العمليات التي
تمارس داخل قطاع غزه وبالتالي الان
اسرائيل امام معضله حقيقيه معضله اننا لم
نعد نحلل الصوره التي تجري في الميدان فقط
وانما نستدعي صور من التاريخ وصور من
المستقبل صور من التاريخ اسرائيل اغتالت
قيادات بارزه في حركه حماس وصلت حد الراس
اغتالت احمد ياسين الشيخ احمد ياسين
واغتالت الرنتيسي واغتالت صيام وكثير من
الشخصيات وهذا لم يطل فقط قيادات حركه
حماس وانما قيادات ايضا داخل فصائل
فلسطينيه اخرى بما فيها فتح والشعبيه
وغيرها وبقيت هذه الفصائل بل تنامت هذه
الفصائل اكثر والتف الشعب حولها اكثر
وبالتالي اسرائيل في سعيها لتقويض هذه
الفصائل يبدو من حيث لا تدري انها لم تعد
او لم تصل الى المرحله التي تدرك فيها
الذهنيه الفلسطينيه والعقليه الفلسطينيه
بانه الشعب الفلسطيني يلتف حول معتدى عليه
من قبل اسرائيل المساله الثانيه وهي
استدعاء صور من المستقبل انتم نشرتم وانا
يعني اتابع تحت الهواء فيديو مهم جدا
واراه من اهم الفيديوهات التي نشرت حتى
هذه اللحظه وهي مساله التصنيع بمعنى انه
نحن لا نتحدث عن شيء ان الان نحن نتحدث عن
رساله واضحه جدا من قبل حركه حماس بان
لديها القدره على الاستمراريه وهي هنا
تحاول ان تجرد اسرائيل من اداه الضغط
الوحيده التي تقدم الان على الطاوله وهي
استمراريه المعركه استمراريه الحرب
استمراريه العدوان وهنا تبدو حركه حماس
يعني تضع يعني ليس فقط على طاوله
الاسرائيليين كصنع قرار وانما على طاوله
على في الشارع الاسرائيلي ان استمرار
العمليه العسكريه لا يعني بالضروره انتهاء
مقدرات حركه حماس لانه بعض القراءات من
كتاب يمنيين كانوا يحاجج بانه استمرار
العمليه العسكريه لامد اطول وهم كانوا
بذلك يدافعوا عن قرارات مجلس الحرب
بالاستمرار قد تدفع الى تهاوي حركه حماس
لحكم نفاذ مقدراتها العسكريه الفيديو الذي
ظهر اليوم وهو يعكس نموذجا مما يجري داخل
قطاع غزه يشير الى امكانيه استمرار
المعارك بوتيره اقصى وبمفاجأة
ما يضطرها الى التراجع انت سالتني عن ابرز
هذه التصريحات وبدات لك من موضوع
الاغتيالات لكن كل التصريحات التي سردت
برايه عمليات تراجع وان كانت بنبره عاليه
بينما لدى الفصائل الفلسطينيه في كل يوم
هناك تنميه للاب دكتور بلال اذا اردنا
التركيز على مساله الصفقه التي يبدو انها
تنضج في الخفاء على نار هادئه وتحيط بها
مجموعه من المؤشرات التي تصب كلها في
اقتراب الاعلان عن شيء ما الحديث عن اطلاق
سراح 30 الى 40 رهينه في مقابل الافراج عن
اسرى فلسطينيين بارزين
والبقاء بلا قتال لمده اسبوعين الى شهر
تقريبا هل هذا يتناقض مع الهدف المعلن من
حركه حماس وهو وقف العدوان نهائيا هل
تعتقد ان في هذا التراجع من قبل حركه
حماس يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لم يظهر من حركه
حماس اعلان يشير الى انها قد تقبل بمثل
هذا الطرح لكن هذا الطرح اذا قدم به بهذه
الصوره وكان هناك تجاوب من قبل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه مع التعاطي معه اظن انه سيكون
من خلال ضمانات من قبل الوسطاء القطريين
والمصريين بالاضافه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انه سيتم على ارضيه وقف اطلاق
النار بمعنى ايجاد مخرج لاسرائيل بنيامين
نتنياهو الان لا يستطيع ان يقول انه سيوقف
اطلاق النار ولذلك اللعب على المفردات هو
لعب من اجل حفظ ماء وجه اسرائيل ب بشكل
يعني مختلف عن المفردات التي يمكن ان تقدم
على انها نصر لحركه حماس كان يشار مثلا هل
يمكن ان نفسر الان ما الذي يقصدونه
بالتغيير العسكري تغيير المجرى العمليه
العسكريه هذه كلمه قابله للتاويل حماله ل
الاوجه وبالتالي اذا ما طرحت على الطاوله
هذا معناه ان الطرف الاسرائيلي معني
بالتراجع لكنه غير معني بتقديم هذا
التراجع على انه رضوخ لحركه حماس وانما في
سياق تغييرات للعمليات العسكريه وبرايي
انه كل التصريحات التي قدمت خلال اخر ي 40
ساعه تشير الى عمليات تراجع تدريجيه في
مسار المفاوضات لصالح الفلسطينيين وهنا
يبدو ان ال الاحتلال يبدو ان بن يامين
نتنياهو هو المنفصل عن الواقع كنت يعني
تغطوا احدى التصريحات لبنيامين نتنياهو
وهو يتحدث عن استمرار العمليه العسكريه
وان الدعوه لوقفها على انها انفصال عن
الواقع الواقع يشير الى ان اسرائيل تتراجع
تدريجيا من خلال هذه التصريحات المتراكمه
ويبدو لي ان هناك اوساط في جهات نافذه
اسرائيليه بما فيها المؤسسه العسكريه باتت
تمهد لمثل هذه الخطوات ليس من في اخر 48
ساعه فقط وانما على مدار الاسبوعين
الماضيين بتنا نشهد تزايدا في الاعلان عن
كم الخسائر داخل قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى
ذلك هناك تصريحات يعني اخر تصريح من قبل
الناطق العسكري حين اشار بشكل واضح اذا
طلب منا المستوى السياسي ان نوقف الحرب
سنقف هذا الكلام برايي هو القاء للكره في
الملعب السياسي لانه لا يريد لمس العسكريه
ان تتحمل وزر استمرار عمليه عسكريه فاشله
امام الجمهور الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور بلال الشبكي رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الخليل كان معنا من
الخليل في الضفه الغربيه